[Music]
networking as MBA students we engage in
building our networks every single day
the idea of networking may elicit a
visceral reaction from some yet
stimulate excitement for others for
Jeremiah it's the former let's take a
look as Jeremiah engages in a small
group networking session at an on-campus
Career Fair got this Jeremiah number
talk to you assume the power pose right
oh there's a group over there so I met C
roll with my co-workers when all the
sudden the seagulls hi how are you guys
doing my name is Jeremiah hi hi I'm
Julia what are you talking about I was
just telling a dog and aundrea about a
work event at SeaWorld oh I've never
been to Sea World
but I've been to Monterey aquarium you
see I'm from Monterey
we used to go every other weekend
oh my favorite exhibit with the sea
turtles such majestic creatures
Amy convinced my mom to buy me two pet
sea turtles Oh anyway what's your
background we are all pumpkins I think
this is the fence I think Ruth oh that's
right that's right I used to be a
management consulting as well you know I
was actually the top-ranking consultant
of my class and every single year I was
promoted so every single year I was
promoted um so when you got okay
okay pause Jeremiah is out of his mind
if he thinks that he's doing a good job
at this networking conversation he
interrupted someone mid-sentence was
completely unaware of his audience and
only talked about himself today we're
gonna help you avoid the mistakes that
Jerry Maji made by sharing effective
ways to engage in small group network
discussions many of you will find
yourselves at a networking event in the
near future whether it be here at the
GSD
as you look for full-time opportunities
at EB ELLs in career fairs or further
down the line as you go to industry
conferences to solicit business
partnerships networking is very
difficult to avoid and while most of us
dread networking it's often an effective
way to develop from personal and
professional contacts that can open the
door to new opportunities in the future
you can learn how to become an effective
networker by following a few key
guidelines first Andreea is going to
talk about how to enter a networking
conversation including how to find a
group to engage with and subsequently
how to get a conversation started off on
the right foot
next a Duke will talk about how to
develop rapport and connections with the
folks that you're engaging with and
finally Jeremiah is going to talk about
how to gracefully exit a networking
conversation ensuring that you leave
getting exactly what you want so let's
start how do you enter our conversation
for some that seems very overwhelming
but let's think of the following
scenario you walk into a room in which
the people are sitting down what do you
do you find an empty seat you have to do
the same when people are all standing up
and how can you find your empty seat
body language we suggest you read the
people in the room is the group of
people you want to join with their
shoulders looking towards each other or
open to the room is there actually space
in which you can walk into or is the
group closed that you cannot join them
find a group in which you can
comfortably walk into then we suggest
also to research in advance who will be
there or who will present there once you
get there you know them at least in your
head you'll find a familiar face look
for them around and then find the
perfect
to approach them now you're already
standing in the group how do you start
we suggest you prepare some icebreakers
for a difference in areas so for this we
suggest three strategies the first one
be honest approach this is very
effective because people can relate to
it just be honest and say hi sorry for
coming out of the blue but I don't know
anyone here and I would not to join your
conversation second the flowery entrance
this is when your research might come in
handy walk up to somebody and tell them
how much you admire their work or how
much you like their company they work
for this can work even with people you
don't know
for example walk up to a group and say
hi I heard your laughter from all across
the room so I just wanted to come over
and see if some of these happiness would
rub on me and third getting advice
asking questions is a great way to start
a conversation we such as you keep it
light topics such as hi I've never been
to this event before do you have any
suggestions of which sessions I should
go to and just like that you're already
in a conversation with them now once
you've got into a conversation
the next question that's probably on
your mind or rather should be on your
mind is what next how do I keep this
going now what they spin off of Google
Chrome logo is trying to tell you is
that there are three elements of an
effective conversation themselves the
other person you and everything in
between let's start with them keep the
conversation about them a funny anecdote
comes to my mind early in the industrial
era the building's got taller way before
the elevators got faster now as a result
people started complaining the tenants
were bored of the long and boring
elevator rides
can you guess what was the solution that
elevated companies came up with mirrors
turns out no one found the rights boring
so long as they could look at the most
interesting object in the world
themselves so in our context keep the
conversation centered about them ask
them why they're here how their day has
been and how can you help them second
you now promise this is the last
elevator reference here but keep a 30
second elevator pitch ready about
yourself know who you are what you do
and why you're at the event whenever you
get an opportunity to say that just
chime in
and lastly interpersonal dynamics now
I'm not referring to touchy-feely but
what I'm talking about is have an open
body language enjoy the conversation
show indication of interest lean in and
nod exit a small group
because sometimes feel like jumping out
of a moving car you're always looking
for that pause in conversation to sort
of tuck and roll now because Xing the
small conversation can be awkward here
are some suggestions on how to exit
stage left honestly and with grace this
first technique I call there's more to
see here it is natural when you're
engaged into a great conversation to
just want to stay put
however a networking event involves more
than two points I suggest saying
something like the following and then go
enjoy the rest of your venn it was
really nice talking to you all I'm going
to go meet some nine other people enjoy
the rest of your evening
the second tip I call so long for now
sometimes you have that conversation
that is awesome you guys are both from
the same industry you have common
passions and you know for a fact that
you are going to run into this person
later on try a statement like this I
really enjoyed our conversation talking
about our line of work
I'm gonna go talk to some other people
but if I don't run into you again I look
forward to seeing you at another event
soon third tip I call this this is a
keeper one main reason for going to a
networking event is to grow your network
that means making sure you contact with
persons who you feel will either grow
your knowledge or grow your brand try
this one on for size it's really
interesting talking to you about our
line of work I hope we can keep this
conversation going if I can keep in
touch last but not least I call this
time to balance not every conversation
is a winner sometimes it's awkward
starts and stops or you have nothing in
common
or perhaps you run into that version of
Jeremiah that you saw in the earlier
skate now if you run into that version
of Jeremiah it's definitely time to
bounce try this light on four sounds
very nice talking to you I'm gonna go
grab a drink you have a great evening
much like an elevator pitch a
well-rehearsed situational exit line can
go a long way it is the way that you can
tell people how you feel about them and
where they stand with you so I like to
leave you with this last quote every
exit is an injury somewhere else for you
I hope that's your next great network
now that we shared some suggestions on
how to effectively network in small
group settings let's check let's check
back in with Jeremiah and see what he's
up to
got this Jeremiah turn to questions of
any oh there's a group it looks open
oh and I've been open to be Julia I'll
go there hi pardon me but I'd overheard
you guys talking about diversity
inclusion and I'm really passionate
about that line of work I haven't met
you guys so I was hoping I could come
over and introduce myself my name is
Jeremiah hi
yes to meet you hey I'm a dope nice to
meet you nice to meet you why I'm Julia
Oh in our way why did you guys really
enjoy that programming yeah I thought
the keynote speaker was fantastic her
views on diversity inclusion were
spot-on yeah I completely agree with her
she was just fabulous I also like that
but to be honest I would have laughed
would have liked her to go more deeper
into the risk of her improvement I think
yeah no I actually agree with you what
she said really resonates with me part
of strategy that she suggested we're
actually implementing in our company
right now
oh no way where do you work and how is
that going we'd love to hear more about
your experience was really nice getting
a chance to meet you guys I'm gonna go
check out more of the exhibit
but I hope I get to catch up with you
later on because I'd really like to
understand how you guys are progressing
with your diversity inclusion in your
own jobs
Wow Jeremiah did a much better job of
networking in this situation doing a
fantastic job of finding an open group
engaging in two-sided thoughtful
conversation and exiting with grace and
intent and with that we'll take any
questions
[Music]